this is a plant that i got from my
garden by having a cutting it's a fern
if i take a leaf off of fern
you can see that it's
got the same pattern all the way up and
if i take off one of these side branches
the side branch looks just like the
original fern
and if i were to take off a little side
branch and i can't really do this
without tweezers if i were to let this
grow this side branch and i've taken off
several let me just get it down to that
one that's a smaller version of that
which is a smaller version of that and
if this were to grow out
eventually it would look like this
so this is an example of something which
looks the same on different scales of
length
you start off small you replicate it on
another branch and then you replicate it
and you've got a branch of a
fern
this idea of things replicating on
different length scales occurs elsewhere
in physics for example well not in
nature
for example a bolt of lightning does not
come down in a straight line it branches
and the side branches branch and the
side branches then branch into other
bits and it comes down almost as a
cascade or a river flowing down into the
delta such as in bangladesh you you have
the river coming down and then it splits
into others
little bits and other little bits and
other little bits out into the delta so
you have not just one river coming down
into the delta but it seems to break up
into tributaries and spread out we've
got an experiment a demonstration of a
flow of a viscous
liquid
into a cell and into this viscous liquid
we pour coloured water and it that goes
into a shape which is neither uh branch
it seems to branch and branch and branch
as a example of physics and this is
called the heli shore cell so shall we
have you got it already george
but i find the physics of this
fascinating because here you have
viscous liquid and it's behaving not the
way you'd expect george is going to
squirt in some glycerol which is a very
viscous liquid between these two
parallel plates held apart by spacers in
the corner so squeeze it in george and
make a nice circular
it's now got a circle up to about there
of glycerol
which is the background fluid now george
is going to squirt in a little bit of
this coloured water and that's going to
push
the glycerol further out
but it will also
try and either make a little circular
pattern in the middle or something else
and it's something else we're looking
for
take it out i'll leave it
all of a sudden it's branched rather
like the fern it's gone into little
patterns little
little
i don't know what to call them they like
fronds and then they break into little
two bits at the end this bit that's
growing at the end is probably more
diffusion-like but this looks like a
petals or leaves of a plant
this is not one dimensional this is not
lines coming out
nor is it two-dimensional it's not
fooling this as a circle it's coming out
in the radial direction and then it's
breaking apart breaking apart and
breaking apart
now it's diffusing out but before it did
all that it was
neither one-dimensional nor two
dimension wasn't a filled circle nor was
it little spikes coming out it had some
other quality rather like the fern of
not filling the two-dimensional space
completely but leaving lots of gaps in
between and whenever that happens
when something is neither one
dimensional two-dimensional you have to
imagine that it's a different sort of
object something which has a dimension
between one and two that is it's neither
an area nor a line but some other
structure in between
and those things we have say have a
fractal dimension it's a fractional
number lying between one and two well
not fractional but some number like
1.58359 whatever and that characterizes
what this object looks like this is
called the fractal dimension and people
study fractals in physics as objects in
their own right trying to work out what
the fractal dimension of a
granular gas is or other such systems
and this is a different branch of
physics from the one that is normally
met there's something called dust
bunnies in america
if you go under the bed and your kid has
not cleaned the lino there are little
bits of dust making a sort of
three-dimensional structure with huge
gaps in between and these gaps in
between allow air to flow through it and
it is not one-dimensional well there's a
sort of lines but it doesn't actually
occupy two dimensions but it fills the
volume but somehow it fills the volume
leaving huge amounts of space there is a
material called aerogel or vicor
an aerogel fills a space just like dust
bun is and when you put superfluid
helium through that it changes all the
properties of helium because it imposes
a different sort of geometric structure
on the superfluid helium and it gives
new properties to it as discovered by
moses chan